wir bewerten jeden tag etwas gut oder
schlecht
schön oder hässlich richtig oder falsch
ist aber wann ist etwas wirklich richtig
das gesetz sagt uns was verboten ist
aber wir haben natürlich auch irgendwo
unsere eigene vorstellung von richtig
und falsch
nur so können wir entscheidungen im
alltag treffen impulse kontrollieren und
letztendlich überleben können sie sich
nicht nach eigenem ermessen bewerten ob
es gut oder schlecht ist einen
fliegenpilz zu essen dann würde ich
wahrscheinlich triebgesteuert und unter
hunger hat diesen fliegenpilz essen und
sterben es ist also wichtig dass wir
selber ständig alles evaluieren und
bewerten
aber warum kann es genau das zum
verhängnis werden und die wichtigste
frage von allen
was hat das mit giraffen zu tun herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video
aufwachsen abonniert gerne den kanal
wenn ihr nichts verpassen wollt wir
posten jede woche ein neues video
[Applaus]
[Musik]
silver wings of injury
wieso sehen wie die welt so wie wir sie
sehen was sorgt dafür dass wir an manche
dinge glauben und an anderen nicht trägt
sich unser selbstbild nur durch
schlüsselerlebnisse bücher und die art
und weise wie wir erzogen wurden
sicherlich ist das ein sehr wichtiger
teil es gibt aber auch einen effekt der
euch jeden tag beeinflusst ein effekt
von dem ihr vielleicht noch nie gehört
habt der konfirmation ist einfach gesagt
bedeutet dieser effekt dass wir unsere
eigenen hypothesen nicht testen sondern
bestätigen wollen
ok folgendes beispiel gehen wir mal
davon aus dass die reifen nicht wirklich
existieren
klingt eigentlich gar nicht so
unwahrscheinlich wenn man sich mal diese
unnatürlich langen hälse anschaut wie
die trinken ob durch das man gesehen
egal
wahrscheinlich würde ich mich um meine
hypothese zu überprüfen über giraffen im
internet informieren
leider bedeutet aber selbstständiges
informieren fast immer auch selektives
informieren
ab dem moment in dem ich mich über
giraffen informieren möchte spiel mir
mein gehirn schon den ersten streich ich
sehe eine liste von links also was
klicke ich zuerst an
nach einer studie der universität
amsterdam werde ich unter bewusst einen
link anklicken der auf den ersten blick
mit meinem weltbild übereinstimmt wir
filtern also heraus was uns nicht in den
kram passt wegen des konfirmation weiß
habe ich eine verzerrte wahrnehmung
meiner umwelt im internet lese ich dann
vielleicht etwas über den langen hals
von giraffen der trotzdem nur aus sieben
wirbeln bestehen soll
ich habe vorher in meinem leben noch nie
eine echte giraffe gesehen also gleich
sich diese information vielleicht mit
meiner vorherigen hypothese dass es
krachen gar nicht wirklich gibt
als nächstes lese ich dass giraffen von
der regierung gebauten roboter sind
ich sehe dieses video von einer
fehlkonstruktion und meine hypothese
wird noch weiter verstärkt wir lieben es
halt einfach richtig zu liegen
ab jetzt nämlich selektiv im alltag
immer mehr hinweise war im zug saß die
waffengegner auf einmal geschlossen
wartungsarbeiten im internet finde ich
gleichgesinnte leute die auch dieser
verschwörung auf der spur sind
die nachricht über giraffenbaby sin zu
ablenkung tier dokus
das propaganda ergo mehr oder weniger
bewusst filter durch informationen die
man weltbild nicht unterstützen heraus
und gegen den konfirmation bei es ist
niemand wirklich immun wir alle halten
an unserer meinung über bestimmte themen
fest selbst wenn wir mit gegen beweisen
konfrontiert werden
aber warum ist das so hierzu gibt es
zwei verschiedene erklärungen
manche forscher sagen dass kognitive
prozesse so strukturiert sind eine
hypothese zu bestätigen
wir können also gar nicht anders als
automatisch nach beweisen
anstatt nach gegenargumenten für unsere
meinung zu suchen das ist quasi eine art
überlebensinstinkt wir bleiben bei dem
was wir kennen alles andere könnte
gefahren mit sich bringen erklärung
nummer zwei ist dass das widerlegen
einer hypothese mit negativen emotionen
verbunden wird schlechten gefühlen
versuchen wir logischerweise aus dem weg
zu gehen
im falle von diesen sogenannten giraffen
könnte das für dich bedeutet dir bewusst
zu werden dass du jahrelang falsch lagst
du hast offensichtliche zeichen wie die
schwarzen zungen oder komischen höcker
auf dem kopf einfach akzeptiert wake up
schiebt man es doch ganz klar ist dass
immer tiere antennen sind mit der die
regierung diese giraffen giraffen
steuert oder ist auch egal was tun also
um nicht diesen konfirmation bis zum
opfer zu fallen
eigentlich sollte es erreichen bescheid
zu wissen und sich mit kritischen
informationen auseinanderzusetzen oder
hier muss ich euch leider enttäuschen
wissen über den confirmation bei ist
schützt uns leider nicht praktisch ist
es also nicht möglich objektiv nach
informationen zu suchen
außer natürlich ihr abonniert doktor
watson auf instagram denn wir haben vor
kurzem mit instagram news gestartet wir
posten jetzt jeden morgen einen coolen
post zum thema wissenschaft oder technik
also quasi sachen aus dem doktor watson
universum ziemlich früh morgens also
können jeden tag mit seinem coolen post
in den tag starten wenn ihr wollt links
unten in der video beschreibung der
allererste ganz oben oder einfach doktor
watson auf instagram würde mich freuen
wenn ich euch da wieder sehr zurück zum
thema besonders schwerwiegend wird der
konfirmation weiß wenn wir persönliches
interesse daran haben dass unsere
hypothese war ist wenn ich mich frage ob
ein partner loyal ist wurde es mir weh
tun herauszufinden dass dem nicht so ist
deswegen frage ich einfach gar nicht und
bin weniger kritisch
ich will es nicht wahrhaben zusätzlich
ist unser weltbild ein großer teil
unserer persönlichkeit und wer will
schon herausfinden dass ein teil seiner
persönlichkeit falsch ist finden lässt
sich der konfirmation preis in fast
allen lebenslagen und situationen
besonders problematisch wird es aber in
der wissenschaft wissenschaftler wollen
eben ihre eigenen hypothesen bestätigt
sehen das hängt mit dem
wissenschaftlichen system zusammen aber
wahrscheinlich auch mit dem confirmation
bayers selbst arbeiten über den
konfirmation preis wird vorgeworfen von
gerade diesen effekt betroffen zu sein
also experimente so aufgebaut zu haben
dass sie den konfirmation weiß
bestätigen
ihr seht also das ist ein ziemlicher
teufelskreis deswegen bedient sich die
wissenschaft dem so genannten carry
viewing bevor ein wissenschaftler etwas
veröffentlichen kann muss es
logischerweise überprüft werden
am besten geeignet dafür sind natürlich
andere experten auf demselben gebiet
peer review ii heißt also dass jede
veröffentlichung von einer anderen
gruppe wissenschaftlern zerpflückt wird
um inhaltliche und methodische fehler zu
finden erst nach dem erfolgreichen peer
review und der überarbeitung darf die
studie oder das paper veröffentlicht
werden
aber auch peer review in hat seine
limits was wenn die korrektur lesen im
wissenschaftler ein persönliches
interesse an der veröffentlichung haben
auch hier ihr ahnt es ist wieder der
konfirmation bars am werk trotzdem
funktioniert peer review ihm aber gut
genug um veröffentlichungen zu testen
ganz ohne confirmation bei ist geht es
halt einfach nicht für euch im alltag
bedeutet das also dass ihr versuchen
solltet euch mit so viel kritik wie
möglich auseinanderzusetzen
hierfür reicht schon der austausch mit
bekannten denn in der diskussion hat der
konfirmation weiß einen großen vorteil
er sorgt dafür dass ich die these meines
gesprächspartners versuche zu widerlegen
während ich meine eigene hypothese
verteidiger da man gegenüber dasselbe
tut sorgt der konfirmation weiß also
dafür dass zumindest theoretisch aus
einer diskussion immer das beste
ergebnis hervorgeht weil halt das beste
argument gewinnt das klingt natürlich
alles extrem optimistisch und natürlich
gibt es in der praxis sehr viele
unproduktive diskussionen ich meine
nummer als beispiel versucht mal
jemandem der noch nie eine giraffe
gesehen hat zu erklären was eine giraffe
ist niemand glaubte die existenz eines
langhalsigen kamel pferdes mit schlangen
muster wie auch dem placebo-effekt
werdet ihr also den konfirmation bei es
nie ganz los
das klappt ist man glaubt ihr angelaufen
das ist doch offensichtlich von der
regierung besteuert also allein die
antennen oder habt ihr mal gesehen wie
die miteinander kämpfen die haut ihre
hälse gegen dann wäre also dass das
wirklich zu glauben dass danke wake up
schiebt da muss man auch mal was machen
das wird ja wohl noch sagen dürfen